[Musique]
lors du speed casting ils étaient plus
de 130 participants à vouloir décrocher
l'un des sept prix du challenge des
créateurs
une sélection qui conduit les meilleurs
d'entre eux à la finale qui s'est
déroulée dans l'hémicycle du département
un événement qui consacre sept créateurs
d'entreprise pour leurs projets et leur
dynamisme à la réunion nous avons un
esprit d'entreprise très développé
le réunionnais est capable à chaque fois
de se reconstruire lui-même son propre
projet et d'être acteur de son projet
malgré les difficultés
c'est pour ça que le département va ici
nous avons souhaité récompenser vers
celles et ceux qui chaque année se lance
cela démontre bien du dynamisme qu'il ya
chez nos ds une autre difficulté pour
créer leur activité créé leur entreprise
une finale qui mettait à l'honneur la
création d'entreprises et le travail
mené par le département et ses
partenaires comme le réseau point chance
pour accompagner les porteurs de projets
les applaudir ceux qui font danger la
réunion alors c'est maintenant à vous
les deux candidats en lice
jose demander d'annoncer les résultats
on y les résultats de la finale seront
diffusés prochainement sur les écrans
télé un vingtième anniversaire qui
nouvelle fois aura mis en valeur le
savoir-faire pays
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]